i love me some james worthy okay and i
remember the first time
that i was at my golf course and i saw
him walk up to tee off with some of my
friends and i just kind of
there you know it's rare it's rare that
i get star struck
but i was pretty pretty impressed with
this this man because of not only his
career
but just kind of the longevity of it the
hall of fame
the the person that he is and now i've
gotten to know him
and i feel like i've become a friend of
his and it's so great to welcome our
next guest
nba hall of famer and laker studio
analyst
mr big game james worthy
welcome james i could if i could only
hit a golf ball like you man
i could only hit a golf ball like you
and score like you do
what's up ryan how you doing brother i'm
good thanks for being here man
good um yeah i was telling the guys
that you are kind of a muse of mine you
and john ireland
uh every time i played with you guys
this
summer this fall i played out of my head
i don't know why but you guys seem to
bring the best out of me
thank you well you know uh it's the
company you keep
uh you know so we we have a good time
out there man we
we get a little bit competitive you know
we've had some
some clutch putts at the end of a round
on the 18
hole one you missed by a centimeter
and then that freaking john ireland you
know he's got the lucky putter but we
have a lot of fun
you know that's what it's all about you
know we we fellowship
to me ryan it's the closest thing
that i've had to a locker room
uh since i retired is you know golfing
with you guys
golfing with my groups playing for 50
cents a whole
and you know having fun so i i enjoy it
yeah that's that's exactly the word i
used i think after the you know third or
fourth time we played that
there's just a fellowship there's
something about being a former
professional athlete regardless of
success just the understanding and what
the transition's like afterwards and
being able to find that commonality so
i i definitely agree with you um
let's go let's go to the nba scene right
now and the team you cover in the team
you played for your entire career
uh the la lakers right now are
without their two-star players and have
lost
four in a row fallen to fourth in the
standings what
uh what does this team have to do to
find a way to manage to stay
in the race for the playoffs when their
stars
aren't there to help them
well we we all know uh they got to try
to win
and they got to try to sustain uh
a level of play until they're healthy
again
uh now when that'll be i don't know uh
the unfortunate thing uh for the lakers
and this
is no excuse you have the injuries uh
but coming out of the bubble uh turn the
season around
and then you know not having quality
practice time they got to do this on the
fly
now they've lost four in a row but i'm
seeing
a little trend of you know how to play
without lebron and a.d if they could
just put four quarters together i
thought they played well
uh last night except for the third
quarter
uh they got some issues they don't have
a rim protector
but they'll they but these are guys that
are in the nba
and and they have to find a way to win
the games for instance they got
cleveland coming up
and i think i can't remember who they
have after that but two games that i
think they
got a good chance at winning and they
got to win those games
and then they got to try to pick off uh
some of these other
other other games they almost had a
chance against philadelphia
um you know they just couldn't close it
out when they got it to buy so
they gotta maintain they gotta sustain
and not dip too far you don't want to
have that play in game
so that's their biggest challenge
um if 100 percent if this team is 100
if 80 stays out as long as they need to
until he's truly healthy lebron comes
back are they
are they the the best team in the nba or
at least the west
right now i put them in the top three
you cannot say that they're the best now
i'm biased
i'm always going to say yeah with their
bench
and they're healthy for what their bench
can do and what a b and lebron bring to
the table i'm definitely going to pick
them
uh but you look at brooklyn you know uh
you gotta
you gotta look at the reality of the nba
and and and with the trade deadline
passed and with some of the
players that miami picked up and the
clippers getting rondo
and you know the celtics making some
moves and you know so
um there are some really good teams out
there man
denver utah so uh i would say that the
lakers are right there
with brooklyn you know the clippers are
good utah
you know denver those are the teams that
uh milwaukee
um there's no there's no advantage
uh with the lakers uh uh being healthy
so
that's the way i look at it and but the
thing is
they got to be healthy speaking of that
health
they've dropped to fourth in the
standings and with the play-in games
like they had a year ago with the bubble
uh there's a there's a reasonable chance
that if
they don't get healthy in in in quick
time
they could fall down to a place where it
could come down to one game
but if lebron and 80 are able to go in
that one game i don't think it's an
issue but if they're not if there's a
a chance that it weighs on one game
and the lakers didn't get to the
playoffs this year how would it be
viewed
in a year where there was so much injury
would it be viewed as a wasted year
would it be
viewed as a year that just you know
we're waiting for the next how would
people in the optics look at a
lakers team that doesn't make the
playoffs in in 2021
well i think anybody that understands
you know sports i don't i think it would
be unfortunate
uh to say that they had a horrible
season in their
you know all the money they spent in the
trades that they made right
uh had to come to fruition you know
especially coming off
of a championship year uh having a short
turnaround but
it would be disappointing let's make
let's make no question about it because
you know uh the lakers are expected to
be in the playoffs
now i'm hoping we'll get a d back
maybe in a couple of weeks or three
weeks maybe
so if we can get him back without lebron
not saying that that's going to be an
instant change
but i think in my calculation if this
had happened in april or something
there's enough time left i think four to
six weeks that you know we get lebron
back for i don't know i haven't done the
calculation we're getting back for maybe
eight or nine games at the end of the
regular season perhaps
with a d and i think if these guys
sustain it
but you're right if they get into that
that one game
scenario you don't want to be there
and it would be disappointing but i
think for me i'd
i'd have to look at why
and you know having your two elite
players out
uh to me with you know with with with
being excuse but you have to take into
account
is there uh we're talking to james
worthy basketball hall of famer nba hall
of famer and
lakers studio analyst um
is were you surprised that the lakers
didn't make any moves at the trade
deadline and is there a possibility with
some of these buyouts coming
that they could make um some waves with
getting
somebody that could bolster this roster
in the meantime
yeah you know i'm surprised i mean
it's it's a it's a sticky situation i
mean you look at the
the players they're looking at which is
you know uh from cleveland
um um because i'm joined by goodman uh
drew uh who's the center from andre
drummond cleveland
yeah i'm sorry i gotta draw the blankets
early for me
uh drummond uh you know the buyout
it's it's it's good now um we don't have
to give up any players
you know i think cleveland probably
would
you know give him i don't know 8 million
or something like that i think he's
close to 11 or something i think the
lakers could do that
2 million 3 million for but then he'd be
a free agency
um he's 27 uh does he want to win
yeah does he want to necessarily make
two million dollars or does he want to
perhaps i mean with new york comparing
15 million
right that's a up and coming young team
with julius randle he might
you know take that that situation so i i
i kind of understand that aldridge is 35
and so i don't know it's it's it was it
was it was tough i think if they could
have gotten something they would have
lowry
um you know what they they decided not
to to do that so
this is what we have we have to count on
getting guys back healthy
i think had it been something available
that uh
rob felinka was not interested in
talking about
you know tucker for any you know swap or
trade so
this is the the place you find yourself
in
when you're injured if they weren't
injured you know we probably won't be
talking about any of this but
we have to uh but i i just you know that
the thing we bank on now and it's all we
have
all we have now is that we get everybody
back out that's it
and if we don't uh then then you're
looking at
you know a situation's a little more
bleak than you know
than it could be we're talking to james
worthy here
nba hall of famer laker studio analyst
here on the
rich eisen show i'm ryan leaf filling in
for rich
we'll get you out of here with this
question um chris brockman and i were
talking about
this new hbo show you know showtime
about the lakers team and the book that
jeff perlman read
uh or wrote and and people are starting
to be announced who are going to play
these these stars and
and as as as time the show started
there isn't a person slotted to play
james worthy yet do you have any
opinions
on who should play james worthy in the
showtime hbo
show coming out next year maybe maybe
i'm not
maybe i'm not in the movie man i might
not be in the doctor's video
i don't i don't have any details man
they might have that you know i might
have got the short end of the straw i
don't know i mean you know
the story can't be told of the the
showtime lakers without
somebody portraying big game james i'm
sorry that's just that's impossible
give me uh give me uh sidney poitier
denzel my good friends who i've known a
long time
leon leon's been around for a while um
you know i don't know man it'd be tough
it'd be tough i don't know who
even looks like me uh a cleon if they
can dunk
all they have to be able to do is dunk i
think and they probably you know they're
probably gonna have the baskets at like
eight foot four or something like that
when they play yeah you know have a have
a beard
you know look serious all the time you
know where the where the knee pads
right goggles the goggles yeah goggles
there you go
i like it i like it hey uh
james thanks for thanks for doing this
man it was awesome seeing you yesterday
i look forward to
getting out on the course with you again
sometime soon uh
um we'll we'll chat with you again when
we know more about this laker situation
thanks again brother
you got it ryan have a good one brother
james worthy everybody
big game james and uh nba
hall of famer hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here